[Musique]
Ah une nouvelle journée qui commence. Va
te faire [ __ ] le sol, va te faire
[ __ ] le plafond, va te faire [ __ ] le
chat. Toujours saluer ses voisins. Je
vous baise. Ouais, moi aussi c'est
grenier. Prendre un petit déjeuner
équilibré. Ah périmé comme j'aime. Bien
choisir ses vêtements. H [ __ ] la
justice. Non. Blip blou.
Non. Ah voilà. Et allez au travail.
Manifestation grève grve 493 terrorisme
génial ma chanson
préférée tout me fait chier cette
journée moisie tout est super
pourri ma
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Salut tout le monde. Bla bla bla vidéo
je pourris.
Aujourd'hui, c'est une belle journée de
merde et pour bien se faire chier, on va
jouer
à des bits et mup. Les Bits MUP, voilà,
un genre de jeu qu'on a pas énormément
abordé dans les JDG. Elle notez
d'ailleurs que je dis Bits Mup et non
pas Bitz Mall qui est une déformation
inventée par les journalistes français.
Le genre est très connu. Golden Ax,
Final Fight, Double Dragon, Astérix, Tur
Arcade, Tortue Ninja, je tout le monde
s'est planté à la première seconde de
Street of R. J'en a plein à la police.
Ah, ça c'est de la police comme j'aime
aveugle et efficace. Bref, maintenant
les bits mup ça existe toujours mais le
gen aura plus ou moins évolué pour
devenir les Bayonetta ou les Devil
mraille. Les bits mup par essence nous
viennent de l'arcade et donc on a
retrouvé un paquet également sur
microordinateur. Il est temps de vous
présenter une nouvelle machine, la Miga
500. C'est en 1492 que Christophe Colom
débarqua en Amérique du Sud et ses
premiers mots furent amigo. Par
déformation, le nom se transforma
lentement en Amiga. Et c'est ça l'Amiga,
l'échange entre les peuples. Avec ses 64
milliards de couleurs par seconde, son
processeur Turbo FDP et son lecteur
floppy Flipp des
Flapigam 256 bits entre les mains de vos
enfants. Franco the Crazy Revenge sur
Amigam. Non pas ce franco là. Un beiz
mupp monde qui aurait pu être fait sous
pain tellement c'est lé. J'ai regardez
ça. Je viens de faire une chope à
l'ombre de mon adversaire et qui aussi
est tellement gore pour rien que ça en
devient marrant. On dirait que le design
a été fait par un enfant de 8 ans avant
sa visite chez Usi. Ça c'est un soleil,
ça c'est un arbre et ça c'est papa qui
tire sur maman. Et sans déconner, ce jeu
existe vraiment. C'est un vrai truc, pas
un jeu fait soufflas. Le jeu est une
succession détron fait part, vous savez,
on dirait la vision des cités qu'ont les
gens de 90 ans qui vivent en Dordogne.
En fait, c'est quoi cette tag ?
Break dance, rock and roll. Ah mon dieu,
les jeunes se révoltent. Et pourtant, il
y a presque de l'effort dans le ratage
complet. Je veux dire, les sprites sont
diversifiés. On croise plein de gens
différents sur le bord des immeubles. Il
y a celui qui pisse du vomi, il y a des
extraterrestres, il y a celui qui se
cache, il y a la plus grande voiture du
monde. D'ailleurs, le jeu se fait en
deux phases. Quand vous avez fini la
phase de baston, le jeu se fait en
voiture. Ah, on a mis le klaxon sous
l'accélérateur, sans série. C'était dit
que c'était une bonne idée. Bah, alors
les bits mup en général, c'est quand
même vachement vide comme type de jeu.
Quand tu as vu un niveau, tu les as tous
vu. Du coup, on passe au suivant.
Guardian of the Hood, un jeu où tu
tabasses des gens dans la rue
gratuitement. Mais où on te dit qu'il
faut recycler
les dents, c'est dans la poubelle jaune.
Ce jeu est un peu comme si Mortal Kombat
avait baisé avec une poubelle et
abandonner l'enfant dans le ghto. Alors
donc l'histoire des gangs du criminels
dirigés par visiblement Michael Jackson
deviennent de plus en plus actifs et
c'est donc à vous et à votre club de gym
que revient la tâche de nettoyer la
ville grâce à vos super pouvoirs de
gymnaste. Monsieur le maire, la ville
est totalement envahie, c'est horrible.
Passez-moi le président du club de
l'association de gymnastique Pigueux.
Tout de suite, les niveaux sont divisés
en deux. Une partie où vous tabassez des
minorités ethniques au milieu des
prostituées, des exhibitionnistes. Et
quand tu as fini un espèce de bonustage
étrange, tu te mets à tabasser les
collègues de ton club.
Un bonustage débile au passage, si tu
perds, c'est game over. Le principe d'un
bonus stage, c'est d'être en bonus,
bande de débile. Donc, on dispose de
tout un tas de cours réglementaires de
la Fédération Française de gymnastique
comme par exemple jeter des vélos
d'appartement sur l'adversaire ou le
lancer de clochard. Tout ce temps perdu
à regarder du free fight.
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
La gymnastique
artistique. Après le vrai défaut du jeu,
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais c'est évidemment les contrôles. Je
veux dire, ce jeu n'a aucun sens. Les
hatbox touchent une fois sur deux, les
coups spéciaux sortent une fois sur 5 et
j'ai toujours l'impression que si je
roulais ma tête sur les touches, ça se
jouerait exactement pareil. Pour le jeu
suivant, il faut se remettre dans les
années 90 et imaginer que Tortu Ninja à
l'époque était un tel carton que tout le
monde a essayé de pomper le concept en
mélangeant les ninjas ou la baston avec
n'importe quoi. Du coup, ça devait être
assez chaud pour les commerciaux de
trouver des idées neuves. Des chats ?
Non, Samouraï Pizakat, des requins,
Street Sharks, des grenouilles. Il y a
déjà Battle Tod, je sais pas, on des
souris. Déjà pris, les motards de
l'espace. Qu'est-ce qui reste alors ?
Les clown et les moules. On peut faire
ninja clown ou transformoule.
Pl, ça sera toi qui et c'est
probablement comme ça qu'en ninja clone.
Je comprends pas ce qu'ils ont essayé de
faire avec ce jeu. Sérieusement, vous
avez un coup de point, un coup de pied,
un coup qui tourne et voilà, c'est fini,
c'est le jeu. Alors, vous pouvez me dire
que tous les bits mup sont pareils, mais
on a souvent des variations dans les
bits mup que ce soit les pouvoirs
spéciaux, les phases d' ascenseur, les
shops, l'ambiance. Je peux même pas dire
des trucs drôles dessus. C'est comme se
moquer d'un handicapé. Et encore se
moquer d'un handicapé des fois. Alors
qu'est-ce que ce jeu pour lui ? Bien une
ambiance formidable, je suppose, quand
vous faites une roulade, ça fait un
bruit de
vomi. C'était plus drôle quand j'étais
défoncé. Ah oui ! Et sinon, faites une
question, pourquoi Ninja ? Mais la seule
explication que je vois, c'est quand
vous faites certains coups, ça fait
vaguement le cri de Bruce Lee. Ah mais
Bruce Lee asiatique asiatique ninja
ninja clown.
Sinon pour transformou, j'ai qui pensait
que ninja c'était un mec discret qui
assassinait des gens, j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a un truc qui colle pas entre
ces deux personnages.
[Applaudissements]
Ninja,
c'est n'allait pas croire que ces jeux
sont un peu pourris parce qu'ils ont
l'excuse de l'âge moderne veut pas
forcément dire mieux. Charles Angel sur
Gamecube développé par
Ubisoft. Qu'est-ce qui pourrait mal se
passer ? OK, donc le jeu commence par
l'intro du jeu où on t'explique que des
gens ont volé la statue de la liberté,
l'Arc de Triomphe et d'autres monuments
divers. Les monolythes de Stone Henge en
Angleterre et le mémorial de Lincoln à
Washington. Waouh ! La dernière fois que
j'ai vu un scénario aussi profond,
c'était dans une BD des Tiny Tunes. Sans
déconner. Non mais sans déconner, vous
voyez là, il y a la Toreffel, là elle y
est plus. Et donc Charlie nous envoie
s'infiltrer dans un packo ennemi pour
recueillir des indices. Et pour
s'infiltrer dans ce pack, il décide de
"Je vous inscrit à un concours de Miss
Bikini organisé sur la plage. Ce sera
une couverture parfaite." Sérieusement ?
Ouais. Il est comment ton bikini ? Il
doit doit y avoir des milliers de
métiers différents pour s'introduire
dans un port. Et le seul truc que les
scénaristes ont trouvé, c'est on pour
les [ __ ] à
[Musique]
poil. Totalement. Est-ce que tu peux
faire au moins semblant d'essayer ? Euh
bon, donc le jeu commence donc au
concours de bikini le plus glo du monde.
Vous faites un petit défilé en petite
tenue sur le podium, vous
descendez et
elle est descendue du podium. Tu es là.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette tête ?
Pourquoi les gens ils essayent de me
tuer ? Et pourquoi moi j'essaie de les
tuer ? Et il est où le packbo ? Je me
dis c'est quoi l'utilité de m'avoir
foutu ici pour m'infiltrer si je dois
tabasser tous les gens entre la plage et
le port ? Mais [ __ ] c'est quoi le
problème avec sa bouche ? On dirait le
Joker là. Bon, donc vous avez un
éventail de coup aussi pauvre que le
tier monde hein. Point pied et sauter en
tapant. OK. Alors, je sais pas
exactement comment marche la gravité
mais je peux affirmer que c'est pas
comme ça en tout cas. Donc après avoir
tabassé sans aucune [ __ ] de raison des
dizaines de baigneurs et de mécanu qui
je sais pas pourquoi ils sont là,
j'étais en train de réparer la plage
avec ma clé qui répare les plages. Vous
m'avez interrompu, je dois vous punir.
Vous finissez la première partie et le
jeu change de perso.
Mais pourquoi vous l'avez foutu en
bikini ? Celle-là, elle était même pas
dans le concours. Et d'ailleurs, OK.
Alors, les femmes cambré, je suis
d'accord, c'est beau, mais ça, ça
s'appelle une scoliose. Et d'ailleurs,
où est-ce qu' range son portable ?
Dylan, monte à bord tout de
suite. Elle doit le mettre sur vibreur
je pense, pour pas se faire repérer.
Alors, les bastons s'enchaînent mais
c'est insupportable. La caméra, elle est
au fraises en permanence. C'est quoi ce
cadrage là ? Je suis censé faire quoi ?
Jouer au jeu ou me masturber ? Bah oui,
d'ailleurs le jeu il est truffé de murs
invisibles. Tous les 3 m, vraiment tous
les trois [ __ ] de mètres, il y a un
mur qui se construit derrière vous. Et
c'est une [ __ ] de ligne droite, quoi.
Vous aviez peur que je me perde ? Et
encore, ça va. C'est pas quand il se
construit carrément devant vous. Pour la
musique, j'ai pas grand chose à
reprocher, mais par contre pour le son,
il y a un truc.
[Musique]
À quel moment tu demandes à quelqu'un de
te faire un son de douleur et il te sort
?
À quel moment tu valides ? Pareil
enregistre. Regardez, c'est mon petit
dernier.
Alors, c'est bon, on y va ? Non, mais
c'est bon, elle est bonne en fait, on
s'en fout. Ou alors Cameron Diaz a été
redoublé par les villageois dans
Minecraft. D'ailleurs, je l'ai pas dit
mais ce jeu est si vivant. Admirer le
monde, vivre en arrière-plan. Je déplace
ma caisse, je sais pas où je vais.
Sinon, ce jeu a un vrai problème avec
les ennemis. Non seulement ils sont
stupides, mais surtout ils sont placés
de manière complètement aléatoire et du
coup ça n'a aucun sens. Mais dans le
deuxième niveau, lorsque vous entrez
dans un espèce de manoir des méchants,
vous tapez quoi ? Des marins pêcheurs,
des mécanaux et encore des baigneurs.
Mais [ __ ] mais je suis où là ? Dans
une partie de cluedo. Arrêtez là
! Mais sérieux ? Mais réfléchissez
[ __ ] ! Mais tu es pas trois fois le
même personnage dans la même pièce
? Bah au moins j'ai fini le niveau. Mais
c'est étrange. Ce début niveau 3
ressemble étrangement au début du niveau
2. Ah ! blement parce que c'est le même.
Le niveau 2 se joue en boucle et si tu
le refais jusqu'au bout une seconde fois
et que tu le refinis intégralement, le
jeu reboucle encore et encore
indéfiniment. Vraiment bravo les mecs et
vive les galets de saucisse. Alors après
avoir consulté le net, il apparaît que
le CD du jeu se met en mode démo si tu y
joues sans carte mémoire dans la console
et du coup vous rejoue le niveau 2 en
boucle. Bon donc après avoir mis une
carte mémoire et fini le niveau 2, le je
t'envoie en Sibérie. Bon au moins elle
sera habillé.
OK je laisse tomber. De toute façon,
visiblement, chaque niveau est un
prétexte pour faire du raccolage dans la
tenue locale. Ah, je dois m'infiltrer
dans des ruines anciennes en Amazonie.
Et si je mettais mes bottes de [ __ ] et
un juste corps en latex ? Le niveau 2
vous demande donc d'infiltrer une base
de terroristes comme le montre
clairement tous ces bureaux IKEA de
terroristes et ses open space de
terroristes he et au passage, vous
débloquez votre premier combo. Un coup
de
cul. Après, vous savez, je vais pas
énoncer chaque petit détail foireux he
c'est juste une accumulation qui fait
qu'au bout d'un moment, tu auras un
flash de lucidité à te dire "Mais
pourquoi je joue à ça ?" Enfin bref,
donc faisons une transition jusqu'à la
fin du jeu. Ah ouais et vive vive vive
les gros nichons. C'est vrai que bon,
j'étais curieux quand même de savoir
comment la statue de la liberté a été
volée en genre 4 secondes. Bon donc je
suis juste allé voir la fin par
curiosité. Alors OK, donc on va dire que
j'ai rien vu, même si c'est plutôt
difficile vu que le jeu te met ça sous
le nez mais bon, visiblement on retrouve
la statue de la liberté dans un entrepôt
et voilà. Waouh ! Ça a dû être dur à
trouver. Je me demande dans quel
entrepôt est enfermé la statue de la
liberté. Et sinon c'est tout ? Enfin, je
veux dire, c'était vraiment ça. Il y
avait vraiment quelqu'un qui avait volé
la statue de la liberté et vous allez
pas l'expliquer. Enfin, je veux dire, le
méchant aurait été un extraterrestre ou
un sorcier, je veux bien. Mais là, et
Stone Age et l'Arc de Triomphe et le
[ __ ] de mémorial de Lincoln. Et il a
fait comment pour voler tout ça ? Il
s'est baladé sur le périf avec son
[ __ ] d'Arc du Triomphe. Allez vous
faire [ __ ] Ubisoft. Ma BD tun c'est un
meilleur dement que votre jeu
[Musique]
[ __ ] Alors journée classique, le jeu
pourri tout
[Musique]
ça. Et bon plus ma journée pourrie est
presque finie, on va pouvoir passer au
dernier jeu. BB Skids sur Supernes sorti
en 94 tiré du dessin animé du même nom.
Donc en résumé, des gamins vont dans un
parc d'attraction avec le copain de leur
mère et voilà tout ce que je sais. Donc
après avoir choisi ton perso, le garçon
ou la fille, le jeu commence à l'entrée
du parc. Il y a des agents de sécurité,
il y a des mascottes, mais ça va,
personne ne vous tape. Du coup, quoi de
plus naturel que d'aller [ __ ] leur
mère ? Alors bon, entendons-nous les
bits mup, c'est rarement connu pour
avoir des scénarios très complexes, mais
bon, c'est des punks ça. Ça se voit
qu'ils sont méchants. Non, vous pouvez
pas comprendre si vous êtes pas né dans
les années 80. Non, mais je veux dire,
visiblement, ces types sont même pas
agressifs. Je peux passer à côté sans me
faire taper. J'aimerais juste une raison
valable de leur taper dessus. Je suis
quoi ? Une racaille ? Bon donc le jeu
commence et on tue les
ennemis. Et on tue les
ennemis. Et on tue les combien de coups
ils font pour tuer un seul type ? Merde
! Et j'ai compté ça prend 35 coups. 35
[ __ ] de coups et j'ai fini par perdre
au timer de toute façon. Le pire c'est
que je suis sûr qu'ils le savaient que
c'était nul. Ils l'ont forcément testé
leur jeu. Quand tu chies dans la
cuvette, tu regardes toujours ton caca
avant de tirer la chasse. Alors, tu as
d'autres coups pour tuer les ennemis en
faisant L plus Y. Tu peux faire des
supercutes qui les tuent en trois coups.
Et à quoi ça servait de [ __ ] des coups
normaux du coup ? Et si je dois passer
tout le jeu avec le bouton L enfoncé ?
C'est peut-être que ce bouton, il aurait
dû être enfoncé par défaut. Non. Bon,
niveau 2. Alors, comment je fais pour
attraper les objets ? A, B non. Ah bah
oui, c'est vrai. C'est vrai que je joue
un seul connard. Donc en fait, il faut
péter les vases avant que notre père les
attrape. Je suis tellement avec les
méchants. Le niveau 3, c'est un des
trucs les plus énervants et frustrant
que j'ai vu de ma vie. Vous devez
trouver la sortie avec cette espèce de
système chaud froid là qui vous dit
quand vous vous rapprochez de la sortie.
Sauf que l'endroit est un des
labyrinthes les plus infectes que j'ai
vu dans les jeux vidéos. Déjà, à cause
de ces [ __ ] de tableau de la
renaissance de merde là qui te molarde à
la gueule en permanence. Raciste. Et
surtout parce que ce labyrinthe n'a
aucun sens. Regardez là, mon
thermomètre, il est rose comme le cul
d'un cochon. Donc ça veut dire qu'on est
proche de la fin. Donc bon, il est un
peu moins rose, c'est pas grave. Je
reviens en arrière. On
va Tu tu quoi ? Quoi quoi
quoi
? Mais pas de problème, il y a encore un
peu de place dans mon cul pour le
dessert. Bloquons la porte tantogier.
[ __ ]
de C'est quoi le but de bloquer les
portes à part de rendre les enfants
malheureux ? Cheusement comme ça, je
peux profiter de la superbe
musique. C'est la meilleure boucle de 3
secondes que j'ai jamais entendu. OK,
vous savez quoi ? C'est la dernière
vidéo avant les vacances. Alors, merde,
voilà le shield code de la soumission et
on va direct au dernier boss. [ __ ]
mais [ __ ] je peux même pas approcher.
Je peux même pas approcher pour donner
un simple coup et mon personnage à la
gravité d'un caillou lunaire. Si
seulement mon personnage était pas aussi
lent dans ses sauts et dans ses
déplacements, qu'est-ce qui me fait
recommencer au niveau d'avant ? Le jeu
me fait recommencer au niveau d'avant.
[Musique]
Oh mon dieu ! Oh mon dieu ! Ils sont
tous
morts. Tout est super
pourri. Je déteste ma vie.
[Musique]
Transformou
transformou
transforboule pour un monde plus cool.
boule,
tu la foule.